now let's get to the new legal trouble
for Jason Sudeikis and Olivia Wilde with
their former Nanny taking the exes to
court
extreme anxiety trauma bonding with
Jason debilitating pressure physical
pain the ex-nanny Lays out the alleged
emotional toll of the couple split in
her new discrimination lawsuit
ET obtained the 23-page court document
the woman now identified as Erica
Gennaro says she was fired over her
mental health after she became primary
caretaker of the children and a shoulder
for Jason to cry on when Olivia moved
out in 2020.
Erica says she felt she had to pick
sides and even went to group therapy
with Jason and Olivia as tensions built
she then claims Jason fired her on the
spot after she requested a three-day
stress leave a source close to the
former couple tells E.T Erica developed
a pattern to try and score both Fame and
money and this is just another Avenue
she's trying in order to get paid
these aren't the first bombshell
allegations from the ex-nanny who is
suing for punitive damages attorney's
fees and the cost of the lawsuit back in
October she accused Olivia of cheating
on Jason with Harry Styles in a rare
joint statement the couple called the
claims quote false and scurrilous
well if sin is believing I believe we've
been seen this suit comes as Jason gears
up for the highly anticipated return of
Ted lasso the emmy-winning series is
back March 15th on Apple TV plus we'll
get 12 new episodes dropping every
Wednesday but after that will there be a
season four of Ted lasso I don't know
it's up to more factors than myself I
think we would have loved to do more but
if this is the end this is the end and
if it's not right
foreign